with the maple leaf leading the way
copycat convoys rolled out across new
zealand
and in europe where french truck drivers
are headed to brussels
they have the courage to do what the
canadians have done before us said this
supporter
will we need our own trucker rally to
end all of this insanity once and for
all
in the u.s conservative media have taken
up the cause the truckers of the world
are uniting with breathless coverage of
the ottawa protest channels like fox
news and newsmax seem to be urging
americans into the streets the folks
here in charge in america don't want us
getting crazy ideas
about standing up for our freedoms in
the same way that is happening right now
in canada
the spread of this canadian contagion is
being fueled by misinformation there are
false claims circulating online that
exaggerate the size and success of the
ottawa protest all meant to inspire
others i do think that a lot of what
what we see in terms of attempts to
organize something are just kind of
people who are just putting it out there
and seeing if somebody will bite
you know i think that should not be
overlooked based on what's happening in
canada plans are now in the works for an
american version of the convoy it would
arrive here in washington on march first
with the goal of disrupting president
biden's trip to the capitol to deliver
his state of the union address
researchers warn opportunists around the
world are now trying to figure out how
to go bigger than the canadians i think
they would love to see something that
had a significant destructive effect
it leaves little doubt the global
movement will continue to spread
inspired by a small well-organized and
well-funded operation that has shown how
easily it can cause disruption
jackson prosko global news washington